مرة قال لي قائد قطاع
الدوريات يخافون منك أكثر مما يخافون مني
من إيش؟
يخافون إني ألقى عليهم ملاحظة
فلاح منسي سعيد الشراري
قصّاص الأثر لما يطلع على الأثر
يوضّح للمحقق بعض القضايا اللي يجهلها المحقق
يعني مثلًا اللي يدخلون الأراضي السعودية
ومعاهم مخدرات
أميّزهم من مشيتهم
مشية رجله ثقيلة
بعدين رجله ما تنبسط، تنحرف
بعضهم يرتدي حذاء حرمة
لكن مشية الحرمة مو مثل مشية الرجال
تختلف خطوتها مثل اختلاف خطوة النعجة عن البعير
أكثر المهربين يستخدمون الإسفنج والجواعد والليات
ينفخ الخطوة حتى يضيع الأثر
لكن والله إن الإنسان إذا شاف إنسان تائه
مو على طريق صح
ونصحه، وأعطاه الأمانة اللي عنده
والنصيحة اللي عنده
والله إنه هو الكسبان
ما يكره قصّاص الأثر أو الرجل الحاسم بالحق
غير اللي عنده لف ودوران
والله أنا أحزن عليهم لوضعهم
لكن أنا في حاجة إني ما أحزن عليهم
لأنها قضايا المخدرات مهما كان
قضية قتل بسوق الخضار بسكاكا
الأثر بساحة
الرجال شال أغراض للحاوية وأنت بكرامة
ودّاهم يوم أذّن المغرب
جوا اثنين، أعمارهم بين تسعة عشر وثلاثة وعشرين
جوا وضروبوه
ضربوه فطاح الرجال
جابوا عمالة، حول الأربعين واحد
ومسكوهم، يوم جينا على الأثر
قلنا يالربع العمالة ما لهم علاقة
الأثر أنا مصوره معي
صوّرته، وقلت أي واحد تشتبهون به صوروه وأرسلوه لي
ما أبغى وجهه، ما أعرفه ولا يعرفني
المشكلة على رجله بس
أنا الحرب بيني وبينه، رجله
رجال البحث اشتغلوا
وبحثوا
وأرسلوا لي الصور
طابقناها على الأثر الموجود عندي
محل الموقع، محل الحادث
والله إنها قصة أقول يا ليتها ما صارت
مو متحسّف على إني مسكته
لكن ودّي إنه ما حصل منه هالشيء هذا
فيه شايب
باع له بيت بـ 250 ألف
قام حط الفلوس بالجاكيت اللي عليه
ولفّه وحطّه بالسيارة
طلع هذاك متابعه من مكتب العقار
ويوم شاف الشايب دخل المسجد
ويروح للسيارة ويكسّر زجاجها
وشال الجاكيت وهرب
فكلّمت مدير البحث، وقلت له السالفة كذا كذا
شوفوا السيارات اللي كانت عنده يوم إنه بالمكتب يوم أعطوه الفلوس
المهم جمعوا سيارات
طلعت سيارة واحدة منهم المتهمة
وأثر السيارة واضح
يعني أكّدت مئة بالمئة
جابوا السيارة وفكرنا، قلت اسمعوا
أظن نلقى زجاج داخل السيارة
قمنا نفتش ولقينا كسرة زجاج تحت
وأجي وألقى دم
لما شال الجاكيت، لما ضرب الزجاج
جرح واحد من أصابعه
قلت بالله شوف لي إصبعه
واحدة من أصابعه تلقى بها جرح محل الزجاج
طلع فوق وقال إيه والله موجود
والله الشكر لله
إيه والله إنه فيه ناس شكروا
وجزاهم الله خير وقدّروا
لكن أنا شفت إن ما فيه لهالدرجة
أهم ما عندي أن الإنسان ما يخفي حق أحد
هذا أهم ما عندي، مهما كان
لو أنه أقرب لك، لو إنه من أحد عيالك
ومسكت ناس كانوا قريبين وزملاء لي
انحرفوا، ولا تعرفهم
ولا لهم مني ولا لي منهم
مُصرّ على إني ما أقبلهم ولا يتقبلوني
ولا أقبلهم، أنا الأشكال هذه ما أقبلها
جت برقية من محافظة طبرجل للقريات
حرّكت من القريات لطبرجل وجيتهم وقت المغرب
يوم جيت المغرب، ولّا والله هذا الوضع
طلعت أنا ومدير الشرطة وشفنا الموقع وشفنا الأثر
أكثر الدم أنا لقيته بالمطبخ
بس آخر شيء والله شفت الدم مرشوش على زاوية الغرفة
أظنه من آخر روح لها
من شعرها
وهي تلف على الغرفة صار مثل الحزام بالغرفة
طيب بس هذا الذهب موجود
وهذه الخزانة مب مفتشة
كيف بيسرق؟
ما سرق الرجال، هذا انتقام
المهم سألت، أنا ما أعرف عنهم شيء
سألت، قالوا والله هذه توها عروس
والرجال له عيال؟
قالوا إيه والله له عيال
قلت والله أنا رأيي إنه يجيبون الولد
جابوهم عاد
ما أدري مين ولده، جابوا مجموعة
طبعة رجله على الدم على البلاط
يعني أشوفه كأني أشوفه يعني خلاص مطبوع بدماغي
قلت هذا الأثر نفس الأثر اللي على الدم
وطلع ولده
واعترف الولد بسرعة، قال نعم
بعدين إيش؟
جرح بالكف
زوجة أبوه، وأبوه
إيش كانت ردة فعل أبوه؟
والله زوجته وولده
زوجته مذبوحة
وولده تحت القصاص
أنا عاد إلّا جريمة القتل
شفت القتل والسوالف هذه؟
والله ما أتقاعس عنها مهما كان
هذا شيء يدفعني، لا يمكن إني أستر
الله لا يستر على اللي ودّه يستر عليه
الله لا يستر عليه
أو أنه يتجاهله
أنا ما أندم
ولا رح أندم بحاجة، مثل عتق إنسان بريء
ما أندم عليها
حاولت تعلم عيالك تقصّي الأثر؟
والله ما حاولت
أخاف أنهم ينظلمون أو يظلمون
أول حاجة
وأنا أخاف من الظلم
الظلم مب زين
ولا يتقبّله الإنسان على أي كائن يكون
الإنسان إذا أبغضته لا تظلمه
لو تبغضه، لو تقول أنا ما بيني وبينه غير ذبح
لا تظلمه
لأنك لو ظلمته، ظلمت نفسك ما ظلمته هو
يعني يا أبو نايف أنا لو يطبع أثري هنا
وبعثره التيار
يصير أثري مثلًا لو كان بطريف
تدري إنّي أنا؟
والله يمكن لا لأني مو معطيها انتباه
لو أعطيت انتباه؟
لو أعطيتها انتباه لو تطبّ إيش اسمه
بتقول هذا اللي سوا اللقاء معي
إيه نعم
إن شاء الله إنّك ما تمشي غير الصح
آمين، إن شاء الله